tuer demain c'est le plus gros vendeur
la demande est vraiment sur ce véhicule
électrique blanche à ces mitsubishi à
boucherville les véhicules électriques
et hybrides ont la cote
ils représentent 50 % des ventes ce
serait qu elle s en est pas complètement
en outre les tensions du gouvernement
d'interdire la vente de véhicules neufs
à essence à partir de 2035 ne fait pas
peur à ce concessionnaire bien qu'il la
trouve ambitieuse
on n'est pas que de mon vieux d'à peine
2 2 % d'avis que l'électrique alors
est-ce qu'un 15 1 qui s'en vient on peut
y en a 35 pour ça je pense que
l'objectif est audacieux parce que un
c'est comme ça dépend à qui vous
demandez trop long c'est l'avis de
l'environnementaliste patrick bonin qui
se réjouit tout de même
donc quoi qu'il devrait être bénis
encore plus rapidement qu'elle 2035
mais venant de la part du gouvernement
legault c'est selon nous une avancée
très intéressant on est souvent tenté
d'interdire les choses mme une fausse
bonne idée selon pierre olivier pineau
c'est comme si on disait à l'avenir on
va interdire quelque chose que plus
personne ne voudra c'est complètement
inutile
et ça laisse croire aujourd'hui qu'on
agit alors qu'il faudrait avoir des
mesures qui nous font agir dès
aujourd'hui parce qu'à la vitesse avec
laquelle se développent les options
électrique
il prévoit qu elles domineront des
jeunes marché en 2035
pourtant pour les concessionnaires la
production pourrait représenter un enjeu
parce que lisent les juges n de
fabrication à l'échelle mondiale peuvent
s'ajuster en fonction de la demande du
québec
c'est la question c'est très ambitieux
de penser qu'elle québec pour bousculer
les constructeurs internationaux
sosh chouchou moins certain et d'un
autre côté je trouve que le modèle du
québec était quand même assez génial je
pense qu'on devrait continuer à
encourager les incitatifs le programme
rouler vert prévoit une aide jusqu'à
8000 $ à l'achat 5000 $ au niveau
fédéral mais au québec à tout le moins
cette aide pourrait diminuer avec le
temps selon le ministre qui doit
présenter son plan d'économie verte le
dis ici jacques andré charbonneau raid
au canada montréal